you can be a Trad wife like my guest SD
Williams a 25 year old woman who has
gone viral I'm sure you've seen her tick
tocks and insta stories and Myspace
posts and zanga journals and AOL Instant
Messenger emojis and anything else she's
been the subject of very nasty articles
by the libs in the media Este thank you
for coming on the show
hi Michael and thank you so much for
having me my pleasure first off
when I first saw your name I was tempted
to pronounce it Este as in louder but it
is este
yeah no accent so every American version
very very American very traditional for
those who don't know Este what is a Trad
wife well a Trad wife is just short for
traditional wife and it is a homemaker
and she cooks she cleans she takes care
of the home and the children if there
are any and the online World gave it the
term Trad wife for short
what motivated you to pursue this
traditional life Were You Raised on the
farm somewhere I mean were you raised in
this way or was it a conscious choice to
become this thing
well I was somewhat raised traditional
my mom was a traditional wife until my
parents got divorced and then of course
that threw our family for a spin and I
think I felt the need to fit the mold of
the world and go get a degree find a
career and I did go to college for
almost two years and then I dropped out
because secretly I always wanted this
lifestyle of course you need a husband
to have this lifestyle so when I met my
now husband
um everything just came into place and
that's really the inspiration behind it
is just it was a dream so do you do you
think that one of the
driving forces behind the traditional
movement
for men and especially for women who
want to be drag wives do you think it's
things like divorce do you think it's
people coming from a culture that is
broken that lived out all of the
pathologies of the liberal Age of
Aquarius hippie dippy sexual Revolution
and realize that the fruits of that
Revolution were just poison and so
they're rebelling
against that
yeah I think that's actually a great
point and at least for my generation I
grew up being told that you need a
career and the boss babe era right and
I think a lot of women are realizing
that they want to embrace this natural
role as a woman and be a mother be a
wife and that is enough you don't need a
career to feel fulfilled as a woman how
has your family reacted to it my family
of nothing but supportive and in fact a
lot of the women in my family are boss
babes but we celebrate each other's
differences and what make all of us
happy and they'd show nothing but
support
well that's wonderful to hear do they
think you're a little crazy I mean I I
know because I have a lot of liberal
family and a lot of liberal friends I
grew up in New York and
perhaps I consciously you know moved
away from some of those ideas too but
they think I'm nuts you know they're
kind of nice about it most of them but
they think I'm pretty crazy do they
think that about you
uh well they definitely thought I was
crazy when I dropped out of college I
was studying to be a meteorologist and
when I told them yeah I met my husband
um I'm dropping out of college they're
like you're nuts
why not well I mean why you don't you
don't need the BS degree and you don't
need the ba degree if what you're going
for is the Mrs degree and you're able to
get that in two years
that's absolutely right honestly I think
going back to our roots and kind of like
doing what our grandmothers maybe some
of our grandmothers did it is really
giving well women this fulfillment and
filling their hearts with joy to take
care of their family
now is there a kind of a
contradiction with being a Trad wife who
is very publicly a Trad wife on social
media meaning you are probably the most
identifiable figure of this whole
movement but it's a movement that says
women should basically be Homemakers and
running private life so is there does it
undermine the Trad life to be a public
insta celebrity Trad wife
that's interesting I get those comments
all the time like how are you a Trad
wife you're online and it's like well I
guess 1950s uh travel wives weren't
traveling so they're using dishwashers
and washing machines if women in the
1800s weren't using those I think as
time goes on like life is changing and
we live in an online world and I've been
using that to my advantage to really try
and Inspire younger women who maybe deep
down have this desire to be a Trad wife
but they're being told no you need a
career you need to support yourself and
you don't need to depend on a man but
that's simply not true you know I don't
know if the analogy to the washing
machine is totally apt because the
washing machine is it's it's a
technology that allows you to live this
private life you know and run the
household more efficiently whereas the
the public facing stuff on Instagram
doesn't do that I think the better
analogy might be maybe Phyllis Schlafly
who I think is one of the greatest women
of the 20th century and Phyllis Schlafly
was in many ways a Trad wife and also
one of the most important political
leaders in American history and she was
a wife and a mother and she had six kids
and also she single-handedly shot down
the Equal Rights Amendment and is is one
truly one of my favorite conservative
movement figures that that you are
living this life yes but the way that we
all interact with you is you are telling
women in a really public-facing way
hey it's okay you your desires that you
have to not like go work at a widget
Factory for Mr McGillicuddy who doesn't
care about you your desire to like have
a family that loves you and work for
them it's normal it's okay you can do
that and and I guess the irony of that
is you've got to be a public girl boss
kind kind of to do that to tell people
either to shut down the era or even to
tell people on Instagram to live a
normal life that's a good point so what
goes into the Trad wife lifestyle you
know beyond what we see on Instagram is
it uh laundry and cooking and is it
having lots of babies is it going to the
PTA is it what you know what what's the
what's the fully fleshed out life look
like Beyond you know a minute or two on
Instagram yeah well I mean a lot of the
time I'm cooking I'm cleaning and I do
like to know what me and my husband are
eating and that's why I cook all of our
meals from scratch watch and instead of
going to get fast food after work and
living in this fast-paced life it's a
slow way of living and we don't have we
don't have children yet we do plan to
start a family in 2024 but for now I'm
just taking care of myself our home and
my husband you know I love this idea of
of slowing down because modern culture
not just on the left but on the right
too
seems totally geared towards speeding up
I'm from New York we walk very fast we
talk fairly fast we you know so I I feel
it too and maybe you want your husband
to be out there in public working fast
working hard bringing home the bacon but
you also need a place of peace
a place to to rest a place to to gather
your thoughts what does your husband
think of all this did he consciously
marry a Trad wife or were you a little
different when you guys met
um well he met me when I was in college
and it was funny actually on our first
date he mentioned that he wanted to
provide for a traditional wife a
homemaker I don't think Trad wife was
definitely not like the word but a
homemaker and he wanted that wife to
take care of the children he he saw the
importance and the value of a woman
creating a warm home and taking care of
the family raising the children ourself
instead of dropping them off at daycare
and having somebody else raise them
right there's this weird phenomenon in
modern culture where the woman who goes
and works for a guy so she can make
money so that the husband can pay some
other woman to raise their kids and it
just seems very inefficient maybe that
ticks GDP up a little bit maybe their
Market incentives for that but it's
completely insane and
for a lot of people
they need two incomes it's very
difficult these days to raise a family
on on one income so what do you say to
those people who find themselves in this
situation where maybe the the wife
doesn't want to go out there and work
but just you know the economy is such
that her husband isn't making enough
money to support both of them or support
you know lots of kids maybe well the
economy will always be an issue I feel
like especially for many families in the
middle class and truthfully my husband
and I have really budgeted
um extremely actually we write down our
budget and we stick with it and we live
within our needs and it's possible but I
see a lot of people going and buying a
house that requires both incomes and if
you want to move into that more
traditional way of living you have to
learn to depend on your husband and buy
a house within means of his income and
not two incomes if that makes sense and
just really sticking with your budget
that's a great Point you're right it
part of the reason that two incomes are
seem to be required now is not just
because the economy has been rigged in a
way that incentivizes it not just
because political forces have
manipulated wages though that obviously
has happened as well that's part of the
story but also because we have all sorts
of nice fancy stuff now and people get
addicted to the nice fancy stuff and the
big house or the gadgets or whatever and
and so you're saying look there's going
to be a cost to anything in life but you
seem to suggest that the value of
traditional living is is well worth the
cost
absolutely
that's great well Essie I think it's
terrific I I think it's quite inspiring
and in fact I know it because I talk to
people who have been inspired by this
idea of tradition you know being a Trad
wife and living that Trad life so best
of luck I think it's really terrific and
thank you for coming on the show
thank you so much for having me Michael
production for my 1950s woman
[Music]
girl that I can come home to